Hi,
welcome to human emotion.
So today we're going to be talking about sleep.
So we know sleep is essential.
In fact,
we spend almost a third of our entire lives sleeping.
We know it's an essential kind of biologically motivated behavior,
and that adequate amounts of sleep are necessary,
not for our normal motor,
cognitive and physical functioning,
even just for survival.
Yet in what way is sleep essential for emotion?
I want to read this quote to you here that says,
if sleep does not serve an absolutely vital function than it is the biggest
mistake the evolutionary process has ever made.
So today we're going to be looking at the question of in what way to sleep
actually serve as a form of overnight emotional therapy,
so to sleep place some important role in restoring our emotional wellbeing,
and what happens when we are deprived of sleep?
How does it change the way we feel,
our emotions,
the way we recognize emotions in others,
and the way we try to regulate and control our emotions?
And how could simply sleeping,
laying in bed and resting so profoundly affect all of these three critical
domains of emotional wellbeing that we've talked about in the course up to this
point.
So today we're going to be starting our first of three segments looking at
emotion and how it relates to different types of health outcomes.
Today we're going to start with sleep and answer this question of his sleep.
Really a type of overnight therapy.
Our roadmap today will go as follows for someone to start with a brief
introduction into sleep.
Then we'll think about what good is sleep for our emotions.
Anyhow,
we'll conclude with our takeaway questions and expert interview.
So let's get started into our basic journey into sleep or what I call sleep one
on one.
So here we have a normal sleep overview and if you look at sleep you can see on
the left hand column it's broken up into different stages,
right?
You have wakefulness,
rem sleep and non rem sleep,
which are stages one two,
three and four.
So it starts again with a wakefulness rem and then non ribs rem stages of one,
two,
three,
four.
And our deepest stages of sleep are actually down here at the bottom of what we
call stage three and four.
So we know that rems,
this really fascinating,
uh,
portion of sleep because it's when we dream,
right?
So we have about five or more episodes of rem throughout the night.
If you look here,
you can see,
you know,
this is an early adulthood.
You see maybe three,
four and often people have up to five of these really intense rem episodes.
And as we'll talk about in just a minute,
rem actually plays one of the most critical functions when it comes to helping
consolidate our emotional experiences and help us awake feeling emotionally
refreshed.
So why don't we now take a journey into sleep?
Am I starting with,
how do we measure sleep?
So sleep is really interesting.
So it's measured using what's called EEG or electroencephalography.
So is a system for measuring electrical activity of neurons in the brain.
So you can see here is you attach a larger ray of electrodes to the scalp.
And by doing so,
you can measure what's these large regions of electrical activity
simultaneously.
And the electrodes are usually placed on the scalp.
Usually you have at least four more the eyes,
nose,
jaw and lower limbs.
And what's really fascinating is what you can get from these electrodes are
different patterns or different,
what they call waves,
Delta waves,
theta waves,
etc. That can tell you exactly which of these stages of sleep a person is in.
Is it rem,
is it stage one,
two,
three,
or four.
So here's an example of what a typical EEG set up can look like.
Secure.
You see it both in an adult,
you can see the different electrodes placed all over his scalp and you can also
see a modified version on a young child as well.
So here you're not only trying to get parameters of electrical activity in the
scalp,
but you'll notice in the small child especially,
you also see,
um,
electrodes near his eyes.
So you can look at eye blinks that occur during rum as well as patterns of
breathing and respiration and job movement that also occur along with different
stages of rem as well.
So now that we know a little bit about the different stages of sleep in a little
bit about how it's measured using Eeg,
I want to take us into a journey through the different stages of sleep.
And each of these stages that we're going to walk through really provides these
vital functions for our biology as human beings as well as we're going to see
for our emotional wellbeing as well.
So if we start with our journey through sleep,
I want to start with stage one.
So you can see it highlighted here.
It's highlighting what they're called theta waves.
And these are again the patterns of electrical brain activity.
Better attain using an EEG measurement,
a hookup that we saw earlier,
stage ones really interesting.
It's often called the gateway to sleep.
So this is at the very beginning of your sleep cycle.
And here most people,
if you awakened them,
they'll actually report that they've been awake the entire time.
So it's this gateway where people,
if they're aroused,
they don't actually quite recognize or realize that they were asleep in the
first place.
So it's kind of an entryway into sleep.
We then move to stage two,
and here is where we really think of sleep beginning,
right?
So here what you see is that what are called k complexes.
So these are large brainwaves in response to environmental stimuli.
So in other words,
our brain is really still responding to things going on in the environment.
You can see these little spindles here in k complexes as well.
And what's really interesting about the k complexities is that the name actually
came from a time when a person was in stage two sleep and someone was knocking
at the door and you would see these large brainwave responses in response to
hearing the knock.
So it just shows that our brain is still responsive and still aware of the
environment around it,
even when it's in this,
uh,
initial kind of where sleep begin.
Stage two,
you also see what are called sleep spindles as well.
So sleep spindles are really important for consolidating what we call procedural
memory,
such as riding a bike.
And interestingly,
the greatest part of sleep spindles is actually in the last part of the night.
So when we wake up too early,
sort of setting our alarm clock before we actually ought to get out of bed,
we lose out on this important consolidation of different kinds of procedural
memories.
So here's stage two,
let's now move on to stages three and four,
what we call Delta sleep,
right?
And these are the deep sleep stages.
So here you can see the pattern of brain waves.
They look really different.
So you're seeing these big brainwave amplitudes,
right?
Um,
so what's happening here is all your neurons are firing in synchrony and it's
not that you have more activity per se,
but they're just all kind of lining up and firing together.
So these stages of deep sleep are vitally important for muscle growth,
repair and sort of general body regenesis.
Um,
and you see here that athletes and young kids actually experience a greater
frequency and percentage of these critical deep stages of sleep.
And then we turned to rem at the very bottom here,
and I put it in red font here because what we know to date is that a lot of when
we think of emotion,
it seems that a big portion of our emotion processing occurs during rem sleep in
particular.
So if you see a bottom,
the,
the waves look really different for rem sleep,
right?
What you're seeing here are these kind of low,
low amplitude waves,
really jagged and you have random bursts of eye movement during rem as well.
So hence we place electrodes around the eyes as well as you put electrodes on
the job because you see,
um,
muscle movement that becomes completely unsuppressed during this phase,
right?
And so again,
we know that rem is not only important for cognitive functioning such as memory
consolidation,
but it seems vitally important for emotional processing and consolidation.
So we'll think about this further as we go through our journey through sleep.
But really focus on rem is perhaps the most critical of all these phases when it
comes to emotion processing.
Another really important component of sleep is that it has a timing or a or a
clock,
right?
We call it a circadian rhythm.
So we know that humans and many other animals have this what we call internal
biological clock.
And this clock operates on a cycle of just over 24 hours and environmental cues
such as light especially serve to help us reset our clock and keeping it in time
with the natural kind of day and night cycles.
This clock helps direct things like the rhythmic secretion of hormones like
Melatonin,
which many of you have probably heard in association with sleep and Melatonin as
we know,
importantly influences our sleep cycle.
So if this biological clock gets out of phase with the environment,
various types of sleep problems can result.
So we see things called delayed phase syndrome.
These are people who maybe can't fall asleep until three or 4:00 AM and really
naturally don't wake up until maybe 12 1:00 PM in the afternoon.
And for them that's their sleep cycle.
But you know,
when it comes to having them sort of integrate with the natural kind of nine to
five schedule that many of us have in the world,
that can be very difficult.
But it just goes to show that we have these internal biological clocks and that
sleep has a very particular timing.
There's a timing that's associated with your natural synchrony,
your biological clock,
um,
as well as external cues like day and night.
So we've done a brief intro into sleep and now I want to turn to what?
Good.
Asleep for emotion.
So let's,
let's look at this here.
What is the evidence that really tells us that something about sleep can play an
incredibly vital role in our emotional health and wellbeing?
So here I have this little circle here to suggest that emotion and sleep have
this really intricate,
you know,
by directional relationships.
So while we know that emotional intensity affects how well we're able to go to
sleep,
so for emotionally aroused or upset,
we have a more difficult time falling asleep,
but we also know it's a two way street,
right?
And that sleep also,
you know,
causally influences emotion as well.
But only until recently did we really understand how sleep and emotion were
interrelated.
Right?
So let's look into this here and see to what extent do emotion and sleep
bi-directionally influenced one another.
So what good asleep,
I'm going to start with the first example.
So one way in which,
uh,
sleep is good for us emotionally is that sleep helps us encode emotional
memories.
So what we see here is a really interesting model that was proposed by Matt
Walker,
what he called the sleep to forget model.
So Matt Walker is a professor of psychology at UC Berkeley who was suggested
that rem sleep actually allows us to maintain what he called an emotional
homeostasis.
So in his sleep to forget model of emotion memories,
he has you think about a time,
for example,
recalling when you know,
there was an emotional memory and it didn't feel as intense as when you first
experienced it,
right?
And he suggests that what rem sleep does is it actually activates brain
structures associated with emotion,
but does so in a way that kind of deactivates the charge or takes that emotional
sting off of the memory that occurred during daytime.
So this is how we suggest that sleep is almost like a form of overnight therapy.
So in a way we almost sleep to kind of decrease or forget the emotional tone of
a memory that occurred prior to sleep.
So you sleep to forget the emotional sting of a memory he would say.
And here this is another interesting study that looks at the effect of sleep,
um,
on different kinds of memory.
Um,
so what you're going to see here,
if you look at the graph,
is that we have both sleep and sleep deprived groups.
So the sleep deprive groups are here in white and what you see is that sleep
deprived groups actually do more poorly at and coding or remembering emotional
memories,
especially positive ones.
Then those who are not sleep deprived.
So if you look here on the graph on the left,
what you see here is that are sleep deprived group and white actually does much
poorer in recalling different kinds of emotional memories.
And in particular for positive memories as you see here on the right hand side
of the left graph under B,
um,
we also see similar types of effects for negative and neutral memories.
But it really seems to be the case that when you undergo sleep deprivation,
you performed much more poorly at remembering the content of emotional memories
compared to a control group in pink that was not sleep deprived.
Yeah.
So what in what other ways can sleep be good or what will go to sleep again for
emotion.
So here's a second example,
and here we see that sleep also promotes and facilitates our ability to harness
or regulate our emotions.
So here
what I want you to pay attention to,
this is a study that was done that looked at,
um,
uh,
one week experiment in lab sleep restriction.
So what you had yours,
participants who were restricted to sleeping only four to five hours each night
across the one week period.
Right.
Um,
and what you see here,
um,
really interesting is that participants who underwent this,
sort of what they call partial sleep restriction,
um,
that they actually listed more cognitive and emotional complaints,
sort of more emotional instability or a lability,
um,
compared to control partisans who did not undergo the partial sleep restriction.
So you can see here,
and we're looking across time at the partial sleep restriction,
you have baseline one and two.
And then the part that's highlighted here in rectangle is when they underwent
partial sleep deprivation for a one week period,
you're actually seeing a significant decrease in their emotional wellbeing that
was associated with,
you know,
endorsing cognitive and emotional complaints.
And then our one and two is a recovery phase after they left the lab and they
were able to increase their amount of sleep.
Right.
So asleep goes down,
as you can see in the graph,
what we're seeing is increases in emotion,
self reported emotional disturbance.
Yeah.
Okay.
We also see interesting studies looking at emotional reactivity,
falling sleep deprivation.
And this is work by Matt Walker's group.
So here this was a neuroimaging study and here he had individuals who underwent
sleep deprivation as well as those who,
what he called a normal sleep comparison group.
And he had people come into the lab and undergo a neuro imaging tasks using that
from rice scanner.
And during this task they are asked to view a series of a hundred pictures
ranging from very neutral to very negative.
What he found very interesting here is actual brain changes in the context of
viewing emotional images as a function of sleep deprivation.
So here you can see that there was greater emotional reactivity in the brain,
especially in the Amygdala.
So this is again as we talked about earlier in the course of the brain region
that's been associated with both emotional salience as well as negative
responsivity.
And we're seeing greater activation in these subcortical Mig amygdala structures
and sleep deprived compared to a normal sleeper group.
We're also seeing the individuals who've been sleep deprived show less control
over regulating their emotional reactivity in the brain.
So it's almost as if we see a loss of connectivity between the Amygdala and the
medial prefrontal Cortex,
which as we've talked about earlier in the course is associated with the
prefrontal cognitive control associated with successful regulation of emotional
responses.
And here you can see some of his graphs that are depicted here.
We just talked about looking at peak amygdala response and we're seeing
increased the macdill response in our sleep deprived group and read relative to
our normal sleepers in green,
both in the left and right amygdala regions.
Okay.
Um,
and here again is the summary of the findings.
Greater Amygdala reactivity,
decreased connectivity between the Amygdala and medial prefrontal cognitive
control regions such as the medial prefrontal cortex.
Okay.
Um,
and here is just another graph just to show you a little bit about this
disconnect that we've talked about between the Amygdala and the medial
prefrontal cortex in the work by Matt Walker.
And this graph in this slide,
what you see here is that with normal sleep,
the medial prefrontal cortex is strongly connected to the Amygdala helping
control and regulate it with inhibitory sorts of processes.
Whereas in without sleep,
the medial prefrontal cortex connection seems to be somewhat severed resulting
in what they think of as an overactive emotional brain.
I he all gas and no breaks.
Okay.
So let's think about what other ways sleep might be good for us.
We've talked about consolidating emotional memories,
emotional reactivity,
emotion regulation,
and finally we'll look at the way in which sleep also influences emotion
recognition.
So again,
this is a study done by Matt Walker,
which is a study looking at the ability to recognize emotional expressions in
the face.
So here,
the bottom kind of take home point from this graph where he looked at people's
ability to accurately recognize emotional faces is that he found that
individuals,
it's called a nap and no nap group.
So he looked at people who didn't,
did not sort of engage in these types of napping related behaviors.
So what we see as the no nap group is more sensitive to negative emotional
expressions,
including both scared and angry faces in the brown and red columns.
However,
what we see here is that the nap group is actually more sensitive to perceiving
happy faces.
So it Matt Walker and college.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yep.
Yeah,
yeah.
So here we look at some work on emotional face recognition by Matt Walker.
And the bottom line of this graph that you're going to see here is that compare
comparing individuals who a nap condition versus those who did not undergo a nap
condition.
We see the following.
So when they no nap group,
what we see is that they're more sensitive to negative emotional face
recognition.
So this is evident in both the fearful faces and Brown and the angry faces and
red.
Um,
by contrast,
the nab group actually seems more sensitive to perceiving happy faces on the far
right here in the green.
So what Matt Walker and colleagues have argued is that sleep seems to reset what
he'd call the magnetic north of our emotional brain compass.
Okay.
So in sum,
what we see is that emotion and sleep have an intricate and intimate
relationship with one another.
And in fact,
sleep affects our emotional life in many different ways.
And we've talked about three broad domains today.
So we see that sleep effects,
emotion reactivity as well as regulation,
emotion recognition,
as well as the ability to consolidate vital emotional memories.
So if we conclude with our takeaway questions from today,
there is follows.
What were the different stages of sleep discussed and which stages were most
critical for emotion processing?
Second,
how does sleep influence emotional memory processing?
And finally,
how does sleep influence emotion regulation and emotion recognition?
Okay,
we now turn from this to our experts and emotion interview series.
Okay.
Today for our experts and emotion interview,
we'll be speaking with Dr Ronald Dahl on emotion and sleep in adolescents.
Dr Doll is a professor in the school of Public Health and the director of the
Institute of Human Development at the University of California Berkeley.
He obtained his MD and fellowship training and sleep and neuroendocrinology at
the University of Pittsburgh and completed a pediatric residency at Duke
University at the University of Pittsburgh.
He led a program of clinical research at the interface of child psychiatry,
pediatrics and psychology,
focusing on the development of sleep and arousal as well as affect regulation
and the relevance to behavioral and emotional health.
And children and adolescents at UC Berkeley.
His current work is now extending these lines of investigation to bridge from
developmental,
social,
and affect of neuroscience to address a broader range of clinical,
educational and social policy issues with a primary focus on adolescence.
So I now turn to a very special experts in emotion interview together with Dr
Ronald Dahl.